so you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
perfect
what's up guys welcome back to the
dope's usual podcast i am thomas
dobasiolo whatever you want to call me
i'm here with marty o'neil what's up
wasn't that bill's jacket is tight it's
[ __ ] playoff season yeah let me just
throw that [ __ ] out there it's fresh as
hell now we just gotta be monetized damn
it
um guys sorry let me get into this i
know i was distracted by the jacket
today
we have a very special guest i know we
haven't talked to you about it yet
trevor but this is trevor wallace how
are you doing today doing good i didn't
bring it up to you i'm a [ __ ] big fan
i've always been [ __ ] for years bro
that's really cool like when uh you know
nick nick cletty yeah yeah back when i
was chilling with those fools when i was
like [ __ ] eight years ago
and then i saw you what three years ago
the first thing i ever saw you do man
that got me hooked instantly i told him
when our booking agent was like what
about trevor wells like [ __ ] get him
yeah guys that drink bang energy oh dude
that's a great one bro that's one that
like that's probably one of my favorites
that's my favorite shirt because it just
like i literally drank three bangs that
really did oh for that video yeah like
like my head like felt like velcro which
i don't know what that means but i was
like
it was so funny because we filmed that
we're just talking about beverly hill
which was funny we filmed that in
beverly hills which is like to have that
much energy in beverly hills and not be
like the richest guy there is hilarious
so yeah that was fun because it just uh
you just run around just off the bank so
like half those like that video wasn't
very scripted it's just like whatever i
feel off the phone
yeah you're like oh he did 40 tapes yeah
well it's funny he kept the good [ __ ]
yeah i did that they uh
yeah have you ever seen the bang ceo he
just dm me like two weeks ago being like
just saw the video i was like he's
[ __ ] i don't know about big energy
really the the ceo looks like he
invented the word pyramid's game he's
like 60. he's like 60 but he's jacked as
[ __ ] and he wears a medallion with a bee
on it from bang he's bawling oh he's a
legend
he's a legend is it a big energy drink
oh he [ __ ] oh sorry we can't cut no you
can say whatever the [ __ ] you want oh
they won't do monetize me they'll
demonetize you yeah they'd be like hey
[ __ ] you drug dealer that's what they're
going to say to me yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
oh real quick do you smoke weed at all i
do at night you do at night yeah i'm a
nighttime guy i'm a [ __ ] kid cuddy
guy that's fine i just want to make sure
because i don't want to smoke people the
[ __ ] out so i just oh oh oh you no i
just wanted to make it you better have
plenty of joints oh no because i don't
really like to smoke people some people
like
[ __ ] yeah i'd be nervous to get high
to go on a podcast because i think i
would just say yeah uh-huh yup yeah have
you ever seen rappers on joe rogan like
yeah they're like they're like i feel
bad man because when you're high you
think you're on some intellectual [ __ ]
but all you're doing is agreeing every
four seconds you're like yeah uh-huh
[ __ ] i know that would be terrible bro
actually well i don't know but sometimes
i've done stand up high when the other
people in the crowd are high and i feel
like there's like this like wave length
so if me and you were both high and then
the people who are listening were high
but that's exactly the show everybody
[ __ ] is high everybody hates because
i'm not high right now but that's when
you get on like some like that's my
favorite it's like when you're just like
it's an idea that doesn't make sense if
you're sober but you're spitballing a
little high and so he's like i think i
know what you're talking about bro i
think almost everything makes sense if
you just keep [ __ ] going you know
what i mean man do you know what no you
get me dude yeah but hear me out yeah
a couple hearing meows yeah that's one
of my favorite things to do is just kind
of like smoke with homies and just kind
of riff a little bit and just see where
you go you know or you just hide by
yourself and you look into a mirror for
too long and you just think about stars
mushrooms when i eat mushrooms i stare
at the mirror i've ever seen yourself
age that's [ __ ] scary right not good
or bad it's [ __ ] awesome like i look
cool at 70. yeah i've done mushrooms
once oh really yeah i did it in palm
springs would you like it all you're
supposed to do in palm springs i liked
it a lot actually i thought it's cool i
uh everything was vibrant as hell this i
mean this studio being going off oh i
did much streams on the show a couple
weeks ago these walls were just doing
this
yeah how did you even focus oh he had to
do all the ad reads that was hilarious i
had to stop he came and sat down like
bro i'm [ __ ] acting like a [ __ ] for
showing up just off caffeine should we
[ __ ] do some key bumps or something
damn you got [ __ ] lice all over you
had to make sure you're crazy bro you
had to make sure bro yeah i know if i
didn't have such a uh insane day today
i'd probably smoke because they're cool
because it is fun just to kind of like
yeah our last guess we don't i mean dr
drew in here yesterday yeah we just said
dr
hi would be funny
he's like hey man these [ __ ] ain't
[ __ ] you're like doctor
i don't know if that's the question i
asked about arthritis but okay
dead-on dude like i just won't always
ask just to make sure yeah some people
might be like hey i need to get the [ __ ]
out of here well do you believe in
contact high
i feel like there's really yeah yeah
because uh i mean if we started smoking
around you'd be high as [ __ ] by the end
of this episode it looks like it's about
the thunderstorm in this [ __ ] oh
because it is it's it's it's um insulin
sounds you still got irrigation in this
[ __ ]
oh that's just for the lights i saw i
saw the poles and i was like damn my
high-ass friend built this yeah well
he's a great high friend he's a
construction guy he was just [ __ ] i
gave him dabs and he just did it all
that's crazy yeah that's pretty awesome
you usually give people methamphetamines
and they'll build stuff the last set was
a 70 year old man shout out to steve
you he works and he he's a psychedelic
enthusiast so i just gave him mushrooms
at the end of it wow this is [ __ ]
awesome the [ __ ] out of that
i mean like also microdosing is so
common these days they're just like do
you want a bite of this chocolate i like
it oh yeah it's okay it's nice to cause
it gives you like an odd way of like
energy
i feel like you just did this to me
it's it's like um
it's like hallucinogenics are just
tapping on the shoulder to be like i'm
behind you
that's a good way to put it yeah it's
not like it's not in you but it's behind
you see i just did mushrooms for the
first time too as a girl this morning
not quite damn near it was very recently
and i had like did you have the problem
where you're like i don't know how much
to take i'm going to try to get my toe
into the [ __ ] it was like
the hard part is you buy them off
somebody who does a fuckton and they're
like do a hat
and you're like yeah but like
you do this on brunch days like what
what what is for me
you know what do i take i have the body
of a scarecrow what am i pulling in and
then if they're like do half then i go
okay let me do half of a half and then i
take that
and then i'm like my [ __ ] no should i
take more but but yeah that's how it
goes
no i uh i think i did the perfect amount
and we it was me and three other people
in palm springs and just like an airbnb
it was like middle of the pandemic and
we all took the same doses at the same
time and it all hit it once for all of
us it was really cool could you talk oh
you're just like no no no it was it was
like a lot of like laughs a lot of like
giggles yeah yeah and uh i remember
eating a popsicle that was pretty vivid
bright as hell
i thought i was at coachella or some
[ __ ] i'm just waving about my face
but yeah we were just no we were all
just like in a pool and then like
everything was so bright staring at the
water was really cool i've only done
mushrooms at night man i've never done
them in the day yeah during the day i do
crazy amounts though and sit and really
like in my room by myself it's [ __ ]
amazing damn because if you're in pitch
black what do you see your [ __ ]
thoughts it's like a projector and
you're just looking at whoa that's
[ __ ] deep it was very yeah but here's
the thing i have a lot of anxiety so i
feel like i'd lock that door and now
just see like godzilla with his [ __ ]
i'll be like come here trevor you
possible i see some scary [ __ ] but never
for godzilla dick yeah what the hard
part is you have to like remind yourself
you're like tripping always always go
you're fine you're safe you're in your
room yeah and then i'm like well but i'm
in the sky like yeah in your room
remember yeah that is interesting but
it's almost like you have to set a
reminder on your phone like you're on
drugs oh i can't even look at my phone
i'll go through every post i ever made
like but why did you say that do you
like put it on the airplane mode and
then like hide it under a pillow and
throw it in another room wow i feel like
that's how you're supposed to do it
it's scary you let your mind be social
media yo
deep [ __ ] right there joe rogan levels
the second i looked down saw my body
went oh my [ __ ] god do you have a
favorite thing to do besides that or do
you put on a certain type of music
all right so if i'm on mushrooms i make
the same mistake every time you ever see
pink floyd the wall yeah yeah the second
he gets in the [ __ ] gurney in the
hospital and starts freaking out going
through i just i i freak out and turn it
off yeah i get about an hour and forty
in that movie and then i turn it off
every five forty is pretty solid though
like i know it's gonna happen i know
what's gonna and i do it to myself
anyway but no i don't have anything fun
to do on mushrooms i just sit there and
contemplate my life
it's [ __ ] but i think that's what
you're supposed to do yeah yeah you know
a bit weird like i gotta go do this and
go paint a fence you know what [ __ ]
josh wolf over here yeah hey i gotta go
to a wedding
i'm gonna eat eight mushrooms [ __ ]
really yeah but sometimes like dude i i
like joints and like maybe a quick rip
or something but i had a buddy in
college he would hit a dab and then just
go to psychology yeah yeah but like that
was his coffee that's where you're at
that's where we're at collectively oh
yeah but is that to like level you out
or is that just do it because i'm like
when i was broke as [ __ ] as a kid i'd be
so happy if i could smoke a bowl for if
i could do something now it's like let
me smoke eight balls and then i'm gonna
go to the bank that's a good way to look
at it it's like a success story that's
not even like i don't even want to smoke
like but if i was 14 fortune you
wouldn't be hyped right now do you know
the worst person was ever in high school
they'd like come up to you if you smoked
and they'd be like you [ __ ] tripping
and they look like oh my god people do
that [ __ ] i [ __ ] hate it i remember
this one kid the [ __ ] kid sucked but
[ __ ] he was wearing jordan you
[ __ ] all those kids are cops now oh
yeah oh you did but it's like it's also
like that's not how you trip you want to
tell me i'm tripping tell me there's no
afterlife when i'm hot like like your
mom's here yeah exactly this isn't going
to do anything i kind of like it do it
slower dim the lights you know but that
never did anything to me well except my
mushrooms that's different because my
hands are little yeah i'm walking around
with t-rex arms and [ __ ]
yeah
um quick question yes sir where'd you
grow up
i grew up relatively out here camarillo
i don't know where that's at hey where
are you from uh merced by fresno
merced trash no
no you like merced i think we should
make the capital of california merced
capital no no i it's um you know oxnard
okay it's camarillo and oxnard it's all
in the same kind of it's down there it's
past us right uh past l.a it's in
between los angeles and santa barbara oh
so to the left yeah you should go 101
you [ __ ] bazinga it down the street
and it's uh what do you do out there man
oxnard
oh i went to the comedy show in oxnard
yeah oxstar's pretty boring yeah yeah i
got you yeah it's a very
yeah i mean you go an hour outside of
any major city and you're like pretty
much this is small yes like when you any
in and out in the world looks the same
to me it's like that's how kind of a
city outside of los angeles looks me
like this is a city i guess um but yeah
i mean i just uh i was outside a lot as
a kid as i was riding bikes or
skateboarding
uh dabbled in the cannabis early that's
always gonna ask were you a bad kid a
good kid not great not great and i have
a question i feel like
you're the kid that had at pta meetings
goes your kid won't shut the [ __ ] up in
class were you that kid cause i feel
like you're like the goofy kid trying to
make people and farting on [ __ ]
in second grade dude i was actually i
was like the opposite i thought the kids
that were acting up were like i'm pretty
like introverted in the sense of like if
i don't like if i don't know the
scenario yeah i i was kind of like i was
like the way i put it's like i was funny
from my friend group but outside of that
if you didn't know me you'd be like this
[ __ ] guy same here they'll say yeah
we're at parties and [ __ ] like can i go
uh right well i'd be like halfway i
don't know i'd be like if you knew me
but oh yeah he's funny but like i think
in high school like when i started doing
stand-up people were like huh in high
school yeah i was 17. oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
doing this for a long time yeah yeah i
started with that but then i went to
college and then i wasn't i was just
like doing frat [ __ ] getting hammered
you know and then
sophomore year vine came around and then
i started doing vine and then junior
year i was doing stand-up again so
i just been making videos and doing
stand-up since like 2013 2014-ish yeah
like open mic stand up or like yeah yeah
just there's open mics in uh san jose
there's like a little scene out there
you could you know get enough like stage
time and [ __ ] but
uh damn it 17 wow man you know what the
what you wanted to do i i really didn't
my like literally my mom like told me to
do it like it was in the paper in oxnard
like ventura there's like those same
their cities are right next to each
other there's a comedy club in ventura
and there's like a cut out that was like
oh stand up comedy classes and my mom's
like [ __ ] you don't do anything else
do this you know and she's like you got
a good personality i think you could
like do this and then i uh it was like
you took like six weeks of like how to
like write jokes and like find and make
stories funny and then
the first show i did was like a showcase
show but i got like this like pop and of
like of laughter and like i had never
felt
endorphins like that because i was never
athletic so i never had that experience
where i like you know hit the grand slam
or i caught the game when he touched
down i've never like had that so when i
had a joke like pop all of a sudden 200
people at once like liked me i was like
oh [ __ ]
and it was kind of like just chasing
that and
i just i don't know i've always just
been comedy like i've never really
watched war movies or serious movies
growing up i don't give a [ __ ] about any
of like the marvel stuff
i you know i just watched like robin
williams and just stuff like that and
i'd be like this is good perfect show
yeah that's what we [ __ ] talk about
yeah rob williams all the time exactly
so i just like never
so it was like this like perfect storm
like coming together really but i feel
like i love that
as a kid so you're not watching brave
hearts and [ __ ] what are you watching as
a kid who's your favorite
comedian or comedic actor growing up
uh probably robin williams yep i love
mrs doubtfire i don't know why but i
[ __ ] just brought that up last show
too really yeah oddly progressive dude
he was out here being a woman dude he's
out here
in like 1900
i don't know uh but that a lot of adam
sandler growing up uh
yeah adam sean was my guy
uh let's see so you pretty much got
shaped the way i was [ __ ] cheap adam
sandler is his favorite person
yeah all-time yeah i just love his
[ __ ] swag how he dresses i love
everything he's always dressed like he's
hung over yeah you know basketball
shorts and a big ass [ __ ] tea and
[ __ ] now but yeah that's different when
you got that much money
i [ __ ] you yeah you when you get that
much money you go through a cycle where
you just kind of like you just want to
be like normal again and then he's like
i'm gonna wear these and one basketball
shorts that hang to my ankles yeah i'll
[ __ ] pull them out to dinner yes
full circle but yeah a lot of that
growing up uh jim carrey is so goddamn
funny ace material is great i love the
simpsons growing up south park
family guy
dude we were at the same [ __ ]
watching the same [ __ ] man yeah
everything you just mentioned all i ever
cared about me too all i could care
about was tv making or was your mom like
yo watch this [ __ ] i'm busy is that why
you're watching tv so much i don't even
know
um
i don't know i was kind of always on in
the background i feel like there was
always just a tv on your cartoon network
kid nickelodeon kid
uh nickelodeon but cartoon network had
some jams i [ __ ] with dexter and angry
beavers angry beers are good and then i
was like all nickelodeon for everything
where are you out with cat dog cat dog
was dope that last episode was sad as
[ __ ] oh it was do you remember that damn
that's [ __ ] deep they died yeah they
[ __ ] died well they're like guys
budget cuts yeah they but they separated
in heaven remember and then cat's like
you want to hang out i forgot him they
just walked away in heaven yeah i'm
gonna take peyote and watch it tonight
i just go to a dog park the next morning
like why
you have betrayed me yeah i forgot about
that last episode um
i want to get high and watch homeward
bound i just talked about homework
boundaries are you serious yeah we just
talked about it it's just what the
hell's happening it's just animals with
famous voiceovers
homer bounds pretty tight yeah i mean
the editing probably had to be atrocious
for like they had to like green screen
the mouse moving for all this what is
this dog doing this
come on cats they just i think they just
didn't even bother they just were like
they didn't do the movie mouse they just
had the voice over i'm pretty sure did
they not no no mal's moved well if they
did it was like [ __ ] was telepathic
i feel like these animals weren't pissed
like dude just take me to a dog park
why'd i go to work [ __ ]
what
6am
you do for call times like [ __ ] we
need bow wow 9am can you imagine how
long that has to [ __ ] take filming
with just animals as the [ __ ] talent
yeah bro do you remember look who's
talking
oh with john travolta and they were they
played babies where the babies spoke and
the babies had dialogue one of the
dumbest concepts ever and i loved it
really yeah
go back and watch that bruce willis
plays the voice of a baby and roseanne
barr plays the other voice of a baby
what is this called again look who's
talking look who's talking
that's pretty good terrible concept but
the movie was 90s great
i gotta check it out yeah i was so
excited you watched all the same [ __ ] i
did so
growing up
you're watching movies and [ __ ] then you
said i started dabbling in the weed so
when did you become that kid that's what
i always ask when's that moment you went
home go [ __ ] i'm with the potty kids now
uh
eighth grade summer so summer going into
high school freshman year
oh okay okay mine was uh
the day the bucks played the super bowls
uh against the raiders and that [ __ ]
horrible game was the night before i was
watching that tv really and i finally
smoked weed yeah oh [ __ ] that was it
yeah you gotta smoke a little bit of
weed just to watch a raiders game just
to [ __ ] chill out a little bit you
know
they're never going to be good sorry all
raiders fans i'm sorry but they're in
vegas now they don't give a [ __ ] they
don't know as long as they get [ __ ]
bets and [ __ ] get drunk
the stadium oh yeah i've heard it's
gorgeous i heard there's a nightclub in
it wynn has like a nightclub suite
there was a twitch lounge in there as
big as a costco what the [ __ ] but you
couldn't go in the twitch streamers are
getting more views in the football game
nobody in there really it was just two
security guards with a [ __ ] empty
costco size twitch room wow yeah they
should promote and promote that [ __ ]
better
yeah i don't know i just i like know a
guy who works at win like the nightclub
out there and he's like yeah you can get
bottle service at a writer's game
which is
[Music]
how does that work that's like doing
[ __ ] drugs at the bank there's some
drugs the dmv like yo it's fun i guess
right you're just watching derek carter
like this dj sucks like yeah it's a
quarterback
i feel so bad for that man he just he's
a presidential dude yeah
i think he's from he played he played at
fresno his brother derek carr played
fresno state
remember
remember derek uh or uh what's his derek
carr what's his older brother's name
remember he was the quarterback for when
the uh texans became or tennessee titans
or who's their quarterback right now
it's derek carr sorry his older brother
was the kid from fresno state oh really
his old brother was the same guy no
there was two both named derek no no i'm
sorry i forgot their parents got a
[ __ ] it up
but they they're from the valley yeah
they have a billboard agriculture right
by my town nice yeah they're from the
[ __ ] valley a lot of [ __ ]
come out of there man but yeah they're
like get me out of here exactly like yo
drugs no football
yeah but that dude that's a way out
derrick and darren darren who's darren
carr he was the quarterback for the
texans for years oh
but derek carr is the one who played at
fresno state and now no he has raiders i
don't know if he played fresno state but
i know his brother did it was like the
talk of our town because nobody does
anything right
yeah we had like two guys play baseball
that went mlb that was about it
you know it's down bad for camarillo
when i'm like the number one prospect of
fame out there i might i might be three
i think those are all big bang theory
that was out there oh my god dude the
guy that wrote sideways the movie he's
from merced and that's it okay oh and
that kid jaylen green for the [ __ ]
rockets just got drafted he's from
merced okay other than that it's just
straight math and babies meth and babies
yeah but other than that i'm cool bro i
mean there's nothing for me to do
yeah the first time i i think i found
out
as a delinquent there was a kid who was
a year younger than me and
he had access to the weeds he's like we
can get it the first time i ever smoked
weed was eighth grade on 4 20. oh
yeah [ __ ] that dude oh yeah high school
next year bro yeah but you know it's
funny it was out of a
it was out of a uh light bulb socket oh
yeah so i was on some merced [ __ ] yeah
also you went with the white guy tweaker
route yeah the socket but every uh well
it was like uh where we put like the pen
cap in it and then uh well you guys made
it yeah you see what you're saying well
this dude was like
he he had parents smoking he smoked like
five times and you know i had access to
google so i was like how to make a bong
right and then we just met up in an
alleyway in 420. but yeah it was a pen
on the light cap and
i don't know he just smashed the glass
and like drilled a hole in it sure
there's better way you know you just go
the metal pen cap route yeah did you
ever smoke in a metal pen cap
no really that was like like
no like you would just take a pen so
that had like a metal cap and then you
twist it off and then you put it in the
back end
like a one hitter yeah but one hitter
but then you put it in a water bottle
like you burn a hole
down
yeah exactly oh exactly cool i usually
just
get a can poke holes with a safety pin
just rip that [ __ ] like that because i
can crush it and throw it away cause my
mom will stab my ass if i was caught
doing drugs oh wow so i would crush that
[ __ ] and throw it over a fence you ever
smoke out of an apple yeah reese only
was like 25 i never did it before there
was always some kid trying to eat the
apple yeah there was always good that
ate the apple yeah like cody's higher
[ __ ] i'll buy you some tacos or
something dude she's trying to eat yeah
you're eating the stem right now
yeah it was always weird like we all
just made loved his granny smith apple
he's like yo i'll [ __ ] eat it
i'll swallow all your spit yeah yeah no
there was always those kids but so
you're an okay kid just smoking weed
and it's funny that you said delinquent
because i wrote delinquent in my notes
oh really were you a [ __ ] delinquent
that's when i wrote my notes
uh yeah
i think so did you graduate i did
graduate oh yeah you went to college
what'd you go to college
uh film and tv
film and the minor in acting so i liked
that you at least had you had your
direction man like you knew what you
were like i like this enough to go to
school yeah i knew i wanted to just do
something like entertainment [ __ ] i
don't know what it was
but like my mom found a paper when i was
in like second grade and it was like you
know when you're like what do you want
to be for your job mindset comedian
it's kind of wild bomb yeah kind of wild
that's awesome though the teacher
probably grading that [ __ ] back then it
was like this [ __ ] idiot
look at me tell me a joke you're bombing
right now but um second grade [ __ ] off
the stage tell me a joke but uh
yeah so i went in undeclared but they
had they had like a film program there
but it's san jose state you know so oh
so you went up there okay yeah norcal
baby
my sister lives in san jose i've been up
i've been
really cool yeah it's okay yeah it was a
bit it was a nice jump from camarillo to
san jose because the camera i was like
50 maybe 60 thousand san jose has a mill
so it's like
you know you can get to a big city and
then i move straight from san jose to
l.a so
did you go to school i did yeah okay
okay did you use that degree
not really no it
i met some cool people and the reason
uh i made some vines
or because people in my friend are like
trevor you got to make this [ __ ] you got
to make the [ __ ] and then i was doing
stand-up in college and you know my
friends support me in college didn't
come to show so i think like being in a
fraternity and
also uh just having a lot of friends and
doing this stuff it kind of pushed me to
do more stuff had i not gone to college
i don't know
had i done more stand-up what i wanted
to what i've stayed what you know i
don't really know what it had been but
yeah jorge navarro shout out jorge he's
the one who told me to start vine
he was like yeah bro people are doing
funny [ __ ] on here you got to do it and
i was like yeah whatever and then i got
addicted i was like oh [ __ ] you can make
funny stuff on here and then like i had
a few things hit
and then after that i was like oh this
is this is how the internet works get a
little snowball effect and you're good
yeah vine was was good until they just
said hey we're [ __ ] done with it yeah
everybody had like conspiracy theories
just weird but like maybe it was like
and i'm not comparing it to the
chappelle show but like do you think it
was like where they're like we gotta
pull it before it's too sad because if
they let vine run into like now like it
would be so many adaptations yeah it's
basically like instagram is all over the
place yeah and then
instagram went oh snapchat we got to get
stories oh tick tock now we need reels
instagram is just like the cousin that
copies you instagram is just literally
standing up on their desk in the
classroom but what are you all working
on what are y'all working on it's like
but nobody's gonna remember be like the
[ __ ] instagram days i think people
will be like the tick tock days the vine
days but instagram they're just like bro
they're trying to make sell [ __ ] on
there
instagram is it's like a facebook mom
forum now
like yo i make
bead necklaces yeah it doesn't make
sense every and then every app has their
like version of tick tock now like even
facebook has like uh stories and [ __ ]
well not even that but they have like a
version where you can just like like
scroll like vertical videos but they
stole that [ __ ] right but facebook has
one which is funny because it's still
the facebook demo it's just a bunch of
like old moms being like uh when your
son doesn't use bologna sandwich that
you carefully pack them and then she
starts like hitting the walls and i was
like whoa
that's aggression yo this social media
has got 45 year old moms [ __ ] taking
their clothes off with this black
silhouette and it's like yo your kids
are in the house [ __ ] hey but that only
fans money i'm not even talking about
i'm talking about the [ __ ] that are
just doing trends
right like you're saying
sandwich yeah [ __ ] off kevin i'm trying
to do the renegade dude that's a real
sense i've heard i don't even know what
that means the renegade that's like the
biggest dance on tick tock that was like
the way i get on tick tock and watch
crazy things and hop off i don't i don't
have some cool like uh
like the uh
you go on a lot i just go on there but
my shit's like world star fight comp
yeah i i've random like
really random like subreddits i either
love like super not reddit what am i
saying like super random like recommend
like like my favorite tick tocks are
like uh redneck tic tac or prison tick
tock you ever seen the tick tocks from
prison
bro they're like innovative as hell it's
not even that it's like yo you're
getting time added [ __ ] you have
an account
my friend had his [ __ ] had his phone
in jail and he called me and the next
day i [ __ ] get messaged somebody else
like he got five months added for that
phone like yeah but if you post a video
that pops off
for five months we went viral i get it i
get if you're in prison like yo but my
video's popping more than yours
they got nothing to do
but it's like crate like dude i went
down like like a was it rabbit hole
but like i watched this guy he he was
making like prison food but like gourmet
but like but it was like it was like
mind-blowing i've seen that guy yeah but
he but he was doing like everything you
could think of and then like how they
would do it in jail it's kind of crazy
dude um i mean
we'll get crazy into it but i know a lot
of prisons [ __ ]
and the stuff that they do in there is
[ __ ] unbelievable
people can make anything out of anything
oh right right it's almost [ __ ] fun
yeah you know what's funny is like you
watch a show chopped and they're like oh
make a lasagna with a [ __ ] sketcher
shoe and you're like bro they can make
this [ __ ] in jail out of imagination
what are you doing on shop
chops is literally just white people in
jail being like what if you had to use a
pilate [ __ ] shut up best company i
watched i've watched almost every
episode of chop during the pandemic jobs
is great and i understand and that's the
best comparison
why people prison tick tock but they get
paid at the end right but but but it's
like it's like it's not even that crazy
it's it's not it's never it's
construction paper in this burger like i
was [ __ ] wrapping it up but jail the
ones that are like crazy because they're
making it's like they use coffee creamer
as milk and then they can make ice cream
and they get the dye off this to to put
food down i saw how this dude was making
tattoos and he was like burning a cup
and then using the ashes and then like
poking in it yeah i get the colors yeah
yeah my stepdad
he told me a lot of [ __ ] he showed me a
lot of stuff the tattoo tattoo needles
in there are [ __ ] mind-blowing it's
macgyver [ __ ] these people are making
stuff out of springs from pens and then
counterweights that makes it go
wow it's amazing very innovative it's
crazy i mean all you have yourself
outside all you have is time in there
and just imagination so you can kind of
figure [ __ ] out you know that and a
bunch of dudes like yo keep your dick
away from me man yeah but i think away i
feel like even that is kind of a
stereotype
or no no i'm just saying not like
getting [ __ ] you know let's just not
get demonetized all right let's just not
give you just make the thumbnail and you
won't get demonetized let's make it awes
thumbnail for us yeah we've ruined a
really great episode going down that
path before
almost wholesome episode we ever did and
then for some reason we brought up
[ __ ]
prison stuff and then we got to
age-restricted immediately oh yeah
because you were talking about it
earlier before we even started because
you do this it's a stiff sucks right
yeah that's your podcast
when did you start that
uh
we're we're three years in oh wow yeah
good [ __ ] we've been doing it for a
while it's just like podcast takes so
long to
you know it's like it's like uh it's
such a brick by brick process but the
bricks are made out of nabisco cookies
and it's like you're trying to build
it's like it's such a small and i
thought since i had like a million
followers at the time i'd be like oh
everybody will switch over and then
they're like no we just want like a
quick two-minute sketch and then some
people are like let me check it out let
me check it out but after you know it's
it's all about consistency you know if
you do a podcast and you're like okay
well we're not going to do this week or
i'm sorry it's running late this week
it's like we got a great producer and my
co-host is also like very on because if
it was just me i'd be like
i'm i just like if i don't see results
immediately i'm like alright on to the
next that's not working boom what's next
but he's like you know like trust it
faith in it and i love doing it but it
is uh
it's a lot of work as you know and and
you know probably trying to transfer
over it but
uh it's cool because you feel like if
somebody comes up to you and they're
like i love your sketches you're like oh
thanks a lot man that's very nice here
but then they're like y'all listen to
the podcast it's a whole new level of
appreciation like damn you [ __ ] with me
on just like hours right on a day to day
yeah they know you they know you're like
crazy like i've had somebody come up to
me and be like how was the dentist last
week and i'm like that's an insane thing
to say on the street
[Laughter]
i know you yeah exactly so i was a
dentist i forget what the question was
but uh just know how long you've been
doing it oh three years yeah three or
three years yeah so who's your co-host
michael blaustein he's just a guy i met
through stand-up he was from new york
lives out here now
but yeah we just we do that we tour
together a lot
how often do the show
uh weekly yeah every wednesday yeah
wednesday at what time does it come out
uh it's usually just like one of those
like when you're when you're up oh it's
like yeah our producer we shoot mondays
he edits tuesday and then he kind of
just clicks send at like three in the
morning to post on everything but yeah
it'll be it'll be up every wednesday
yeah so youtube spotify apple yeah so
it's called the stiff socks box stiff
stocks podcast yeah it was great it's
just like two dudes it's literally just
what you would hear like two 14 year
olds talking about if their parents were
out of town
yeah it's just good
good energy man we like that description
well also when you when you guys reached
out for to have me on this show i saw
you know we you had steve we had stevo
so it's like i saw you've had some some
really cool people man and it's like
it's crazy we don't do a lot of
interview type stuff but every once in a
while when you do an interview it's like
it's cool to be like oh damn we get to
oh it's just you two back oh but just
back and forth oh yeah [ __ ] i mean as
you know probably booking a new guest
every week man [ __ ] job yeah yeah
it's a full-time job and not only that
you're starting chemistry it's like you
guys have a great currency but then you
got to start chemistry with somebody new
every week yeah also if it doesn't work
it probably didn't [ __ ] work and we
wouldn't be friends
and that's fine i'm cool with that [ __ ]
yeah you ever been like five minutes
into an interview and be like ugh that's
gonna be a long one
right now yeah we've logged out
no that we have not yet you said you lo
oh look you [ __ ] out he said you
logged out no
you're like we're good
yeah no we just [ __ ] leave just turns
the cameras off i bet joe had that
though because he recorded for like
three weeks
he reports her through what do you mean
no just straight forward just like oh
yeah some of our shows she's just gone
[ __ ] hours oh yeah so that's that
weed right there yeah yeah
definitely
getting [ __ ] up during the show yeah
yeah we got drunk for a few episodes we
did we got drunk for like 100th episode
got really hammered for that i don't
remember the show ending same same hands
i got blackout drunk with his when his
mom came on oh yeah my mom oh yeah was
she drunk talk [ __ ] no mom's just really
drink i talk mad [ __ ] to her for four
hours
real blue smoke she's just not even here
and you're talking [ __ ] oh she's
watching right now she's a recruiting
character she watches everything oh my
parents watch a lot of stuff i do too
yes the podcast was one where my mom's
like i'm gonna support you on everything
but maybe not the podcast i was like
that's fine i mean it's a bunch of wild
[ __ ] it's just horrendous like
just a lot it's just a lot about sexual
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you know [ __ ]
no i got a girlfriend who is very nice
and i love her but um but it is just
like like a disclaimer yeah of course so
baby if you're watching no but it's it
but it is just a bunch of like [ __ ]
you ever had that or what about when b
you know but it's just not i don't even
know i don't even know how to describe
it it's like a male caller daddy type of
thing
okay that's cool so if you know what as
long as you know what you want man
that's really yeah we stumbled into it
we started with like a format that we
thought was gonna hit and then we just
it just wasn't like we were like let's
go out and do an activity and we'll go
skydiving then we'll talk about it
and then we realized we had a lot of we
had to plan too much so lots of fun
because it is oh yeah it's like all
right for recording tuesday monday we
got to do a thing and then we'd film it
and then we try to like edit a vlog
oh my god in hindsight it sounds like a
great adderall idea you're like yo it's
like a
because people will watch for the vlog
but then they'll stay for the podcast
and use this whole like
entrepreneurship we thought we were on
and then it turned out people just liked
us riffing just going back and back
because we were talking like 40 minutes
and then we like oh [ __ ] we should
probably talk about that
you know the pure in santa monica we
went into nobody gives a [ __ ]
got you so that's that's cool though you
it's challenging
and it's like it's your show you can
change this [ __ ] to whatever you just
press stop right now but i have to go to
the bathroom [ __ ] you it's good do
whatever you want yeah it's cool that's
what was cool about it and not like
you know if i've tried to pitch some
stuff and around like do the hollywood
route stuff but it's like you know you
if you want to just you can't just stop
you can't like it's like there's so many
people involved this and that but the
podcast space is just like it's me
co-host and our producer gabe and we're
just like a little trio it's like
whatever you want to do it's pretty neat
so it's the best thing that's just me
and marty so it's
it's the best whatever we want to
[ __ ] do man it's really fun as long
as you do [ __ ] that fans will like and
if we like it
that's what matters yeah if you're
genuinely excited about it then they'll
be like look he likes it we like it
[ __ ] it yeah because you always gotta
remember like when someone makes a trash
song like no one's gonna like like i
guarantee you someone's gonna [ __ ]
like it out there you'll have one guy
that appreciates the [ __ ] that's all
that matters what i heard from somebody
is as long as you're not losing
followers that's good like like to try
on air you know some people might
comment be like yellow [ __ ] was mid
whatever but as long as at the end of
the day you're still like either you
know same place we left off or like
slightly higher you're doing okay that's
just good way to look at it yeah i mean
it's just it's hard not to value your
last thing
meaning your your whole worth like if my
last video bombed it's hard for me to
not be like oh my whole career is
bombing you're like
well that's a content creator thing
though man yeah that's the brain behind
like right is my [ __ ] [ __ ] sucking
right now you're just gonna be the best
video ever right and you go oh it's
shadow man oh you made me feel like an
[ __ ] for two hours [ __ ] you right
because you're just basically going on
like this is
like the current what i'm putting out
now is the current me it's always good
as your yes as your last
uh project yeah correct well i [ __ ]
get i used to do a thing on instagram i
was telling you before my top three
pictures when you scroll like no they
got to be the best ones yeah so when you
see it it's like a [ __ ] ad like oh
he's just tight you get like in the mind
of the consumer you're like if somebody
goes onto my page they need to see this
and this yeah because if i saw it like
who is this guys this is [ __ ] awesome
i get it i totally understand i've
struggled through that [ __ ] for [ __ ]
years man i guess i was doing instagram
skits for [ __ ] five years straight
and doing nothing else but that but
that's how i built the phone i mean like
you man you've been doing these skits
for how how long you've been doing just
the skits online
uh not counting vines since like 2017
oh the ones for your youtube channel
yeah i started posting on my youtube
like 2017. yeah do you see i deleted a
lot of the early ones because they're
mid as hell but you know
but but yeah it's like
my goal was just like when i moved out
here i was like let me just try and do a
video once a week one one video a week
and then after a couple maybe like a
year and a half almost two years one
finally hit in like 20
18-ish and then i was like oh all right
let's keep throwing [ __ ] wood on the
fire you know we got some heat let's
keep going
good [ __ ] man do you really write those
out or do you kind of just have a loose
idea and go out and film it it's about
half and half
you know sometimes we'll go out with
something that's just like a very loose
premise and be like oh this is kind of
like kirby enthusiasm they're just like
there's one end goal let's try to just
here's the way there here's a story for
the scene let's do that but sometimes
i'll write a few lines just to
uh take a soft skeleton again exactly
just give us a route and kind of a
thought process to like follow it after
nice dude i think that's exactly how we
do this [ __ ] but yeah it's just it's
more fun it's just like so hard for me
to just sit down and be like oh what is
funny you know i just feel like [ __ ]
i feel like some idiot in a coffee shop
being like haha this is what the people
want but it's like all the best lines
that i've said and all the lines that
people quote and all that yeah
it's just what the you almost impressed
yourself the brain spits them out you're
like
yeah but that's the [ __ ] because like
you're excited about it it's not and uh
yeah i don't know it's just like you're
in that zone and then you're just saying
the [ __ ] that you think of that person
or that character whatever might be
would say and then it just feels uh
it feels like you like i don't even know
it just feels right instead of like
being just sitting in your room be like
is this funny you know i'll i'll write
as much as i can in the room just kind
of get the wheel going but the best
stuff is out in the field i think
what's up guys just taking a moment real
quick to thank one of our sponsors this
is manscaped if you've been watching the
show for a long time manscaped has been
here since almost the beginning but this
is a new beginning this is 2022 it's
january start your balls off fresh
that's never going to get old thank you
guys before we move on let me get right
into it www.manscape.com
forward slash yolo that's 20 off plus
free shipping new year new you not gross
so the performance package that's an
all-in-one all right that has the
lawnmower 4.0 that has the weed whacker
which is the nose trimmer ball toner
baldi owner for those that need it the
travel bag and it comes with the
underwear that is the ultimate gift box
just hand it to your husband and say do
better or show it to your wife and say
yeah you're welcome so once again guys
this interests you whatsoever and also
like i said it really helps us if you
guys are going to buy manscaped use our
code marty and i appreciate it it helps
the show so once again
www.manscape.com forward slash yolo
that's 20 off of anything even if you
buy one thing and then free shipping
remember two million customers can't be
wrong and four million balls can't be
wrong
what's up guys just wanted to take a
quick moment to talk about one of our
sponsors this is fanduel vandal
sportsbook it's an app that you can
legally bet on your favorite teams or
maybe you're not favorite team you just
want to win some money right now if you
go download the fanduel sportsbook app
use code dope as usual your odds for
winning whatever you bet are 30 to 1
odds please when you download the app go
through it it shows you every single
state that it's legal sports betting is
not legal in every state so make sure
you're in a legal state before you start
also for everyone out there it's just
like anywhere else you got to be 21 and
over and yes guys we understand that
this episode comes out on monday and the
games just pass but we're not filming
this monday and we don't know who won
yet me being a packer fan i am so
excited the last time i watched the
packers niners playoff game i was eating
milk duds eating bologna sandwiches with
my grandpa on sixth street and also just
say it real quick packers in the
playoffs the bills are in the playoffs
it could be a bills packers super bowl
if say you have the fanduel sportsbook
talk to your friend next to you say hey
download it if your friend downloads it
with a referral from you
you get 50 bucks the person that
downloaded it your friend gets 50 bucks
all right fanduel sportsbook is giving a
lot of deals to our fans so if you've
ever wanted to do any sports betting
take advantage of it right now playoffs
are here 30 to one odds five dollars can
get you 150. with that being said shout
out to fanduel sportsbook thank you for
teaming up with the podcast back to the
episode
question when you're falling asleep is
that where you find your ideas
uh as i'm about to pass out i wake up
and [ __ ] write okay i was just
wondering when you do skits and [ __ ] are
you in the [ __ ] bathroom are you
driving and go hey write this down yeah
that's what i do a lot it's uh
it's sometimes it was a it's a lot of
like observational stuff that i'll see
or i'll be talking to somebody and i'll
be like dude i saw this one got the way
to the airport today and he just sounds
like oh wait i gotta write that down all
right
yeah it's like oftentimes i'll like say
and as i'm saying it i have to hear
myself to be like oh dude that's that's
a character right there
uh but yeah my notes have my phone it's
just the same flooded with [ __ ] flooded
with some decent sun it's all over the
place but yeah that's what it is it's
just go through and go you're not funny
sometimes [ __ ] oh bro
are you [ __ ] kidding me i'll be like
i'll be like okay i'm in town for three
days i need to make a video this week
and i'll look at my ideas and i'm like
what
huh i thought this was funny at one
point or i'll get ideas if i uh
you know if i'm just like if i go to the
gym or something because my brain is
just i'm not talking to anybody but i'm
like doing an activity i'm lifting
weights you're kind of zoned out but i
don't really be going to the gym that
much so
but sometimes i'll be like i need to be
creative go to the gym then however you
feel after the gym you feel like all
creative and [ __ ] i [ __ ] with that so
it's all over it's just they're they're
literally all around i mean you drive
around one block in los angeles and
you'll be like i got four videos
got four videos bro thing i really liked
what you do is like you said you were in
a character it's now it's like what
would that [ __ ] think
i've never done that before i [ __ ]
love that dude yeah it just it adds
a lot more layer yeah yeah because then
you can go like okay what does this
person wear where would they be living
you know i did one in denver the other
days we were doing shows out there and
it was just like all right we're in
denver what type of people live in
denver what do they wear what's the
environment and then people scrolling
are like oh [ __ ] you know i made so many
videos in my apartment in my house
people are just like man i've seen this
before but when they see you in a
different setting like oh what's this
yeah you know i had like a mullet and
i'm in colorado people are going to be
like whoa oh oh [ __ ] this is something
new so i think it's a fun way to keep it
fresh and also it's like uh
you know sometimes i'll if i'm trying to
write it i'll like put the
costume on or whatever it is
just uh
but that's like the most
that's like the most level i'll go i'll
just be like all right look at this
[ __ ] dumb outfit and i'll be looking
in the mirror be like all right what
would this guy say would how would this
guy would he listen to but you know i
went to acting school and all that [ __ ]
where they like tell you this they're
like this is how you find a character
what would they listen to what would
they eat oh you know what what's their
their fantasy what's their [ __ ] what
kind of dirt bike do they have or is it
a vest but it's like you know it's like
usually pictures this person has a whole
then it makes it super easy to write for
that person and say then as you get the
whole [ __ ] characteristic it's like
talking about your friend like no that
fool's an idiot and he throws up
everything he drinks
but let's talk let's talk right i get it
that's exactly because those little
traits bring out so much more detail
then they feel like it was like oh is it
25 year old
uh who's lazy not motivated you're like
okay that's so vague but it's a 25 year
old who can tell you the narrative of
every episode of angry beavers you'll be
like oh this [ __ ] got stories
you know so it's like that little detail
like it says so much about somebody and
that's even you know the jokes in there
too be like oh this dude listens to
alien ant farms that's his favorite band
[ __ ] and you're like but you hear that
right and i know what that guy does he's
wearing a track suit yeah he's on i know
that he's on the fbi wanted listen
but like you hear
that's why specifics are so important
because you say something and it like it
you feel you feel something when i said
alien ant farm you feel someone you say
like i saw this
guitar on the [ __ ] steps concrete
yeah
so you can picture that it's so much
more than like oh he's a 25 year old
rock or whatever so it's like i'll
picture that like what did you listen to
and that's half the jokes right there
the guy that lives at home he only
studies nfts like yeah i got it we
i
know
this
set up exactly i love that but it just
that helps a lot [ __ ] oh yeah dude just
clarifies and if anybody's listening and
and they're on the creative space it
just helps like really
it sounds corny and cliche to be like
what do they eat for breakfast what are
they but that that like you're writing
the jokes when you're because a lot of
the funny is just the reality of it you
know if i did a
just like a shitty like i don't even
know like you're just like a shitty type
of person character and you're like oh
dude eat slim jims for breakfast you're
like i know this guy yeah instead of
being like you know it just it helps
really uh
no i totally understand it's like
watching it's watching a movie and the
guy wakes up and still has his shoes on
and he threw up like yo
this guy's going to be bad yeah exactly
i get it i get that's cool man i did
well you went to action school that's
[ __ ] awesome
that's sick but yeah so like in college
i feel getting really learned that that
was all like stuff i learned out here i
think but i mean i don't know if you go
to college great you meet a lot of cool
people uh i think if you don't go to
college and you want to but you don't
i'll say this you can just get the same
cool experience but like move somewhere
else you know you don't need to go to
college your hometown just fill it out
it's never gonna you're always gonna be
like yo no you're not like that yeah why
are you doing that that's not you like
will you also change it'll be hard to
challenge yourself in your hometown
because it's easy to fall into your own
be like oh man i'm good comfortable i
just showed a guy that never left his
hometown i literally just showed him the
yeah like dude stop that was written oh
so
show
my [ __ ] god that's everybody i know
that still likes football it's like
you're the football coach now
yeah
i know it's just like sick it's just so
easy to and maybe they like it but it's
so easy to just convince your brain to
be like dude this works for me i got a
girl she works at [ __ ] yolanda's i
got a [ __ ] two-year-old and i'm
coaching jv ping-pong so things are
looking up
oh god that's exactly the thing is you
just embody eight [ __ ] people that i
know right like yo i just yep i couldn't
imagine wanting to teach
like football bad enough to want to
where you're like yeah you can teach
football but you also have to teach
history class like you gotta really love
football
to learn about the gulf coast war yeah
so what a bad education system that the
[ __ ] jock is like no you just
geography now right but it is weird
because there's like actual people who
went to college like i want to study
geography and like cool we have to beat
out glenn who's glenn okay well he's the
guy reversing that [ __ ] mazda miata
blasting music that's real and he's a
softball coach but it's like i went to
school for geography this [ __ ]
just like softball
how are those two ever in the same world
small town [ __ ] but that's that's what
it is that's crazy
that's true though but none of the
coaches ever like taught like
trigonometry no it was sex ed my coach
[ __ ] you really yeah it was like my
football coach was the sex ed teacher
that's like that's the easy [ __ ] you
could have done [ __ ]
talk about stds yeah but they didn't
they didn't get into the nitty-gritty oh
they did i was like where's the [ __ ] at
somebody show me
somebody help me out here i'm 27. i
still don't know where this [ __ ] is
yeah but but that was i don't i think
they just try to use sex ed to like
scare you yeah that's exactly what it is
uh the lady who taught us sex ed she uh
missed rwanda damn damn yeah she was uh
she was intense
she i just she's an intense name for a
sex head teacher yeah well she
uh i'm just trying to like she had
really short hair and she'd like she
she's an old white lady yeah a white
lady she's adam's shirt she's like the
lady from incredibles that makes her
suits but
yeah i don't know this makes sense but
she talked like a crow
like something about her like like it
was very like poignant it was like ah
she beg and then you're going to do and
it kind of sounds like
she was intense
but she was the one but that's why i
like sex said yes i like
dude my spanish teacher she was pretty
cool miss zeiler she had a uh
she had a she had a really soft voice
and she would lose her voice a lot so
she'd wear like a like a ricky martin
headset and she had to shut the door
that's what i got she had and then she
had like a speaker box on her waist and
she'd like turn it up so that's kind of
that yeah and one day i went to school
high one day i was like bro i was
[ __ ] lit it's just kind of hard
but yeah that was uh so you know spanish
very little i can tell you library
that's about it okay i got kicked out of
spanish class really yeah because
they're like you only speak spanish in
this class i'm like but [ __ ] it's the
first day jake but you have to speak
spanish and i'm like i don't understand
what you're saying are you not fluent
not only in my family really yeah i was
gonna say when everyone else does
everybody in your family speaks spanish
but you didn't
oh uh my mom raised me and like
my dad's whole side speaks spanish so
okay the only one all my cousins there
my little brothers and sisters that my
dad had all speaks man how many white
kids were like cheating off your paper
you're like i don't [ __ ] know either
oh i got kicked out day two really my
white friends ethan shout out to ethan
is fluent so he's sitting there like you
need help like bro i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna get kicked out and i got her
and she how did you get kicked i started
speaking french i'm like [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm like i'm not going to say [ __ ] in in
spanish because [ __ ] teach me first i
ain't called [ __ ] right but she was
hella pretty and that made me feel weird
my spanish teacher i'm like i feel weird
talking [ __ ] to you and then she made me
stay after she goes what can i do to get
you out of my [ __ ] class really just
sign up baby how are you telling me that
you run [ __ ] you can get me out she
didn't have no hope for me man
wow i don't know spanish still so when i
go to mexico i'm just
they spit on me they're being brown and
not speaking spanish dude that's crazy
it's always a disappointment that's
crazy how many people try to like cheer
off you probably day one and you're like
dawg i don't [ __ ] you just drawn that
one s all the kids used to draw well
everybody's in my town's magazine
i'm only brown kid i don't know spanish
so if you speak are you allowed to take
spanish class if you speak english
speakers yeah yeah but it's it's a it's
uh spanish fluent spanish so it's
[ __ ] advanced to [ __ ] oh oh because
it's separate right it's like
is this right like maybe
there's like someone with vowels or it's
like [ __ ] i don't know i think
there's like if you speak it's like it's
like you could be fluent but the way
they teach in a school it has more
vowels or something like that i have no
idea yeah i know there's [ __ ] trash
spanish and there's real spanish
my grandma and grandpa speak both so i
don't [ __ ] know the difference
i don't talk to any of my cousins or
aunts or uncles yeah i took two years of
that
but i do remember i went to class high
one day i i smoked before school like
twice and one one of them was spanish
and
i could barely hold it and see him mrs
eiler with a goddamn [ __ ] boombox on
her waist i was like please don't call
on me oh my god i was doing [ __ ]
lines in class and [ __ ] i was a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] oh damn yeah i was just
getting coked up for [ __ ]
it was like always it's like on the pad
and you just hand it back really what
grade is this
10th or 11th but
it's merced man yeah we're doing not
meth so it's [ __ ] great there you go
yeah it's all just not mad honestly if i
was a teacher i saw kids doing coke i
wouldn't be mad i'd be like hell yeah
now y'all [ __ ] pay attention you know
what i would do i go bro
stop
what the [ __ ] are you thinking yeah
because now that i think back i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i was getting [ __ ] up and selling
hello drugs at school
yeah but it's also like i said it's also
said so entrepreneurship if you think
about it true i mean that's a weird
almost my whole damn life and it turned
into this so i'm [ __ ] fine with it so
yeah yeah yeah i mean you're making
business you're just learning how to do
like taxes and [ __ ] i just pay this guy
now exactly try to do it once and i'm i
i should have paid attention in math
class
yeah i don't even think they taught us
that though they taught me numbers they
can't teach you how to flip a [ __ ]
like an eighth into where we are today
basically right that's true they can't
do that they're just like what if we did
division but longer it's long division
day like what the [ __ ] does that even
mean i missed long division day in
fourth grade you just don't know how to
do it that's one of the things we
brought up he's got a photographic
memory he means yeah
like scary photographic was just one day
at your school well i missed the first
steps oh for one day isn't that crazy
and i didn't feel like you'd be three
pages away from everybody else and
you're like that's how i felt
i stopped college because of that really
missed two days of algebra went
i'll come back next year isn't that
crazy or you just like pick up your head
and you're like you're four pages ahead
and you're like
college not for me man so for college
for you you went to a frat how did you
get in uh was it one of those tvs yeah
have you ever heard of the elephant walk
so we all get naked and you hold these
other shafts no that's not true that's a
real thing that's not real i swear to
god
you must get this school [ __ ]
canceled
san jose i think if you went to like a
big football school like arizona or you
know anywhere in the south that's where
the hazing was standing ours was just
drinking and like sleep deprivation like
and then you just had to clean the house
a bunch of [ __ ] yeah just oh yeah you
know wild [ __ ] good not really no so i
have one friend that did a frat like he
told me what they didn't go i would have
fought everybody in the room yeah you'd
think that but you're like you're you're
like so in it you all it's like you just
want like it's i don't even know it's
like you see these guys on the campus
they're getting [ __ ] they got a cool
frat house they're just the man the
guy's just drinking natty lights on
tuesday at like noon and you're like
it's a gang basically yeah well you're
just like i want this life so bad that
like
if if a random guy in the street was
like yo do 20 push-ups and shock on this
four loka you'd be like all right a
little aggressive i'll try it right i'll
try it yeah
you know i might burp after throw up but
when you're in this frat mentality
you're like it's like it's not
brainwashing but like it's just very
like
they sell it and you're like do you want
to be a part of this or what dude damn
so you say you'd like beat people's ass
and there were a few people that dropped
at the last second because we had hell
week because it was an eight-week
process and then weeks seven to eight
was that was the one where they [ __ ] you
up while going to school yeah oh
dude this and like we had like 40 people
on like pledge class like the group that
like of our freshmen that were about it
and i think like four of them dropped
out last week because they were on that
where they're just like nah [ __ ] this
all right but i get it bro it's like
you're trying to figure out like
engineering school and then trying to
maintain like a normal life you got a
girlfriend you alex pulls his dick out
on you yeah exactly and you're like what
do you mean i have to eat salt and
pepper off this
diet
so
dude they they blacked out the windows
and they took our phones so you have no
idea what time it is okay and you're
just cleaning the house non-stop drunk
and then they'd be like trevor you have
class right now and then they'd throw
you to class and then they would like
then they would like they would have
people check up on it you know how
lecture halls had like one little window
in the in the door and if they caught
you sleeping
they really in class yeah well because
like during this week nobody had sleep
because all the kids are sleep deprived
right so they're taking off time to go
hey that [ __ ] fell asleep he's
out yeah because then
because well no no they wouldn't kick
you out but then they'd come back and be
like yo trevor was a sleeping lecture
and because of that you guys are only as
strong as your weakest link
more punishment so i mean they could be
lying or whatever the [ __ ] but like this
is all mental this is all mental games
to be like
you know [ __ ] so if you pass all this
you just go you're allowed to the
parties years on the front yeah
so if you if you're not in the fight you
can't go to their parties unless you're
a girl basically
i can see the appeal of some people who
wanted to go to these parties like dude
you get hooked you you buy into the
lifestyle it's like you know at first
like i think any person would like see
crossfit
these [ __ ] idiots with man buns and
then you go to a few glasses and you're
like i get it i get it you know so am i
comparing a frat to a crossfit maybe but
i think same [ __ ] yeah yeah but i think
it's one of those where like
because even my roommate at the time of
college
uh
i think he might have been he was close
to merced i forget he's from a city out
there but
he was like i'm not doing all that [ __ ]
that sounds wack and then like he saw
what i went through and then the parties
i was going to and he's like you know
what i'll check it out and then the
second semester he ended up joining but
he wasn't like a dude who'd you think
would be like on that [ __ ] either
but he's like honestly sucks it's the
way you put it is it's the worst time
you never it's it's the best time you
never want to have again i think
wow
because it's like it's a [ __ ] up me
though
yeah no camaro though yeah no camaro or
you know bad first marriage
yeah
dude i don't know what it is about army
dudes like yo i need to marry the girl i
met tonight well isn't it
isn't it [ __ ] what is that is that
don't you get more money or you get more
money as a married person but also
you're attached to somebody
but bro military wives be cheating all
day they'd be cheating that's like the
night before they even get out of the
car they're like
all right it's sad and true i know bro
and they're like doing the highest form
of like
they're fighting for a country and
you're fighting for a guy named brock's
[ __ ] you know it's just not it's sad bro
the thing is if you're a military dude
and you cheat on your wife and you get
caught in those uh in the
like you know the towns that they have
like apartments for people that live
there
you lose rank you can lose some of your
pay really oh [ __ ] yeah did you know
that if you get caught cheating your
wife in the military you can lose your
[ __ ] rank
wow insane bro but the other way around
it's like no no
she's taking care of your kids
there was that like one famous like
photo went around the girl she like did
a porn after she was seen in the same
blood you ever see that it was a blonde
chick she's wearing like a green shirt
and she's like with her man before he
deploys and then she's like on a porn
set wearing a green like the same
t-shirt yeah you you can look it up yeah
he [ __ ] left basically oh but stayed
after
straight after she still had the parking
validation for the military base on her
car windshield
yeah bro it's like a pretty big meme if
you like her or like a photo of just
something but like this blonde [ __ ] yeah
she just does a lot it's amazing
i don't know i don't know wrong people
to cheat on too you know you got right
back from war train killers yeah cheat
on like a [ __ ] salesman or something
maybe a substitute teacher well salesman
be like i gotta go to atlanta for a
conference you're like cool i'm gonna
[ __ ] the neighbors
i don't know man that's crazy i uh yeah
i don't
military life has got to be
so hard on the mental life
everybody i've ever talked to goes bro i
wish i never went really yeah but i mean
i'd rather work at mcdonald's yeah then
go to the [ __ ] donald's
oh really what were all those goddamn
beeping noises like
okay it's not like you're a landing
spaceship
everlasting gobstopper
from willy wonka okay yeah that's
exactly what they mean there's just
always that one like sound it's like
it's almost like teeth it's like
teeter-totter i was like
that's the meat is it yeah it's time to
[ __ ] put it i'll be so i'm the only
person to speak spanish i just got [ __ ]
on really every [ __ ] day like no you
touched it because nobody wants to do
the meat what's wrong [ __ ] sitting
there spore and sweat and when you open
it up the grease hits your face so
you're automatically awesome sticky
i was shocked to find out that
mcdonald's use real eggs they crack them
in the circle and [ __ ] isn't that true
it comes out of a cup it comes out of a
milk carton yeah i've seen them loading
that [ __ ] into mcdonald's on a pallet
yeah it's it's it's it's a big cart egg
or whatever it's liquid egg you put it
in a circle and you just pour it
god take yeah
you also think tick tock would like hire
some kid like yeah you're working
mcdonald's now shut up here's fifty
dollars use a real leg yeah yeah okay i
can see that you know tick tock is just
taking over earth right now it really is
but it's okay did you uh would you hook
up your homies when they come through
mcdonald's or we just you didn't even
tell anybody
um
no there is no hooking up really at
mcdonald's well everything is also
amazing you're standing right there
right there's nothing and once i got
there my i can't eat this [ __ ] no more i
was like yeah
i was going to school [ __ ] selling
hella weed and i got mcdonald's just so
i can have a check
to show that like no
this is where my money's from right
because it was just kind of weird like
yeah driving a g-wagon with no job never
never like that i just smoked i sold
weed to smoke weed
like i would sell a pound keep a qp
smoke that qp even though it's all
profit but by the time i read up again
i'm like oh i have a qp and another i
saw that one right i was just such a
[ __ ] weed smoker man i mean was
would you rip off white kids
[ __ ] no hell no my friends are my
friends uh but like would it when it
ever got like outside of your circle i
would never soul wheat outside of my
circle okay well
because it's like then you're talking
about
now you have to deal with gang bangers
and now you have to do what
[ __ ] are like why are you
selling packs yeah was always just like
one guy be like yo [ __ ] can my homies
homie hit you up oh that's no i never
skipped nobody man i could i just
couldn't
do it and it was the most fire and i was
charging so [ __ ] much that i would be
played if i played somebody right it's
also like point one of a gram is going
to make you that much more money there's
no sense that and people weigh sex
people were waiting like yo what the
[ __ ] oh this is true oh if you had a
scale and you bought weed you knew
better that's that's like when somebody
holds up the 100 bill in front of you
dude i'd never
wow i never thought about this
in front of them no no when you get home
i've had people wait right when they get
home like
you're a [ __ ] liar i have two
scales yeah but no when it came to that
point i just ripping people off was just
never
i just never really got
once i started actually selling weed i
couldn't yeah well yeah i think it's
just you're already making enough money
it's like all the white kids are my
friends man yeah i like i told you like
i had one mexican home you had chilled
with in high school everybody else was
though crazy cky white kids
that's how that's how i grew up like we
all watched cky and do [ __ ] coke and
treat keystone light all night yeah you
know white kid [ __ ] white kid [ __ ] and
making the threats of your father yeah
no
none of us had dads
turn up mercedes
hell yeah man that's pretty much uh how
it happened but
back to your uh your college days you
graduate then you go straight back to la
to start working on entertainment yeah
just trying to figure it out because i
was doing vine and stand-up my senior
year
and
and i moved to los angeles and this was
like right when like behind was like
still around was kind of tapering out
16.
what year 2016 yeah 2016. yeah so this
is right around when i thought like um i
was like you know mine's kind of tapered
out let me just go fully into stand-up
like let me just stand up sam so all i
was doing was just open mics every night
and then
like 2017
about a year of just stand up i'm still
doing stand-up and i'm like you know
what let me start
i think facebook videos are gonna be big
because the the virality you can share
[ __ ] on facebook not like any other app
at the point at the point where it can
snowball you know all these people share
then they see it in blah blah blah blah
and i started posting videos on facebook
and youtube and then i finally had
something hit on facebook and ironically
enough also youtube the same video kind
of hit and i was just making fun of like
the zoomies employees if you know you
know skate shop
i tried to apply there they made me what
song would you sing i went
i'm gonna leave that's smart that's like
but that's their job interview yeah it
was terrible like that and have you ever
done whippets you're like yes like
you're hired
but yeah i actually got caught from
stealing at a zombies which is ironic
because the first video i blew up off of
on the internet was about zoomies and
you got stealing in high school i got
caught okay what
here's you put it on and walk out even
worse what do you think is you think i
did that i think you might have did this
one
and put it in your pants yeah walk out
with a bulge
okay
so you had me in the first half okay
okay i put it in the pants but i have
too much guilt on the inside that i got
something else and then like went to go
buy it at the counter
to be like
yeah
and not even a big ass beanie by your
dick well i get to the counter and he
goes hey uh you might want to take the
beanie out of your pants too we have
cameras back there we've been watching
you
yeah
yeah they let you go
yeah it was just like oh they didn't
tackle you no i mean dude if you're dumb
enough to be like here's my credit card
i would like to pay for the first thing
you're like all right this guy's not
this is his first time stealing this is
cue first and last
uh i
i don't know i remember stealing alcohol
in college same thing i [ __ ] i stole
a bottle of uh absolute vodka put in my
pants and then bought gatorades
idiot because i have like too much guilt
to be like i get it i can't steal
everything i get it i have to get this
giant corporation ralph some money yeah
i know what you mean i've never stole
i've talked about this recently really
i've choose my mom's like you're gonna
go straight to hell so as a kid i'm like
don't [ __ ] steal [ __ ] but i would be
like hey man if you're gonna steal that
bottle i'll give you 10 bucks and i'll
drink it with you but i'm not stealing
[ __ ] right
the bottle runs do you ever have to cut
the black caps off the top of the dude
well the time we stole this bottle was
like in the back by the bathrooms and
they hadn't put the lids on the caps and
so it was almost like asking we were
going we were going to a party and i
remember bringing that bottle being like
i had i told every girl i was there i
stole this i was like do you want a shot
of this stolen alcohol that i stole
like going up to cops i'm like yeah i
stole this dude [ __ ] what's up dude
arrest me uh
exactly yeah but that was uh other than
that not really
yeah it's not worth it because when
you're young you can get away with it
but once you turn 18 you're like i can
do time for this yeah and plus
i mean do you really want the [ __ ]
meaning that much never it's never like
i don't know i don't know what i was
doing i just i thought nobody else was
in there and i didn't see the worker and
i was like i could probably get away
with this did you grow up with money
your parents well off no no they're fine
but it wasn't like uh like like i
remember my dad lost his job and there
was like like a month where my parents
were like you're like nobody in this
house is spending a dollar like we're
[ __ ] we're staying on this so no and
i think my parents did a really good job
of spending me the value of a dollar and
i think i really i never was like trying
to just
get money and blow it
god she got you yeah
i think that you did great with that but
are you an only child i have an older
sister she's older yeah she was really
like she was only with the good grades
which sounds cliche but like she got
great grades
uh got into really good college and then
i was just like y'all are smoke weed out
of a light bulb
so elephant elephant walk coming soon
yeah exactly i think my parents were
just happy that i found a passion as
young as like 17 to be like oh it's
amazing yeah because for them i mean
it's like 18 is coming up is he going to
college is he staying in the house do we
kick him out and then like fourth
quarter player trev was just like comedy
and then they're like
thank
god
at first they were like yeah we're glad
we're glad you like it as a hobby and
then the more i started to do it they're
like cool but like also get a job and
then when i told them i was quitting my
job to just do this full time they were
like honestly we knew this was coming
we're glad you're doing that [ __ ] man
super supportive support yeah supportive
background that's great they're great
dude they live like vicariously through
me like my dad will just text me and be
like just to look at your website your
dallas shows aren't even up here you do
not care about this [ __ ]
good man [ __ ] they're on it that's
that's so good to have like someone to
support you yeah my dad was like booking
my flights for like the first like two
years i was like touring and really
is your dad he's retired now what did he
do sales he wasn't like he sold like
bicycles like you know diamondback
bicycles [ __ ] yeah yeah he worked for
them for like 20-something years damn
you must have had the plug as a kid i
had to do a bike ride
uh i uh did i
try to stand on the thinking i don't
think [ __ ] but
my dad was like so in the bike world
that like pegs were like cliche and like
like and she's just amateurs yeah he's
like you wouldn't put a spoiler on a
ferrari trevor what do you mean come
with them dad yeah exactly but no my dad
got me like this [ __ ] like little
sick like bmx bike that was like [ __ ]
dude you work for diamondbacks yeah wow
those are expensive as [ __ ] right now
those are reselling the [ __ ] oh
pandemic or you think just no no og did
you know this about og he's a [ __ ]
avid bmx bike collector he has so many
classic dinos and [ __ ] i'm not surprised
by that though yeah my friend who does
it there's thousands of dollars for
those really right now yeah damn dude
yeah but that's cool man you have a
supportive background that's one thing i
wanted to ask where your are your
parents down do they like the [ __ ]
yeah i mean it's uh
i think
in the be it's hard to believe believe
in something in the beginning if you're
not seeing results you know it's like
because views are just a number in a
sense you know yeah like your parents
like okay cool like this his video got
50 000 views that's cool but like is
there money is this the long-term things
this is a job but like i remember we
were in [ __ ]
santa fe new mexico of all places my
mom's like let's go there for vacation
you know just white people people random
well i'll tell you what they got great
food out there and they got [ __ ] fire
margaritas out there but this was
probably 2017 right after this first
like video started to hit and we were at
lunch and somebody like came up to me
was like dude you're trevor wallace i
love your videos and that's the first
time my parents were like oh [ __ ]
awesome
i was [ __ ] playing so cool like to
try and not freak out because this is
also maybe like the second time i've
ever been like recognized so i was just
playing a cool song yeah what we're
talking about who got the fajitas all
right [ __ ]
what's the move after this
it's your parents yeah so you're trying
to go to one oak or what but was it
gradual
when like doing your live comedy
noticing that the people that were
coming out to the show yeah were from
yeah it would be like i would post local
shows either in los angeles or like
ventura in my hometown and i would have
maybe a few few people come out you know
and and then it just kind of like got
more and more and then i just like you
know the more videos i was posting the
more views those were getting it's just
like this kind of like
collab or not collab but like they both
kind of rose at the same time which was
really cool it's like a counterweight
like this just pop and more fools are
showing up to your show right exactly
yeah exactly that's just the way it
works dudes what's good for you what's
good for
because views don't give matter but they
[ __ ] do when it comes to oh that
turned into a ticket sale exactly right
yeah it matters man like 100 a lot of
people like you don't get paid for when
did you start getting paid for doing
content or do you
yeah youtube pay you in [ __ ] yeah yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah uh probably like
probably like 20 like end of 2018 was
like when i saw like i checked i was
like oh this could this could help with
rent you know
got you because i know like oh i'll give
you a 300 certain like bro that's yeah i
live in l.a yeah bro i remember i
[ __ ] i did like a brand deal i think
it was an energy drink kind of up near
merced i forget where it was was it
called 5150
are you [ __ ] with me that's mike and
iraqi that's one of the best homies from
merced that was the one yeah mike and
rocky made up 5150 in merced are they
still around i don't know but the last
time i saw him he was driving a truck
bro [ __ ] yeah you have 5150 mikey rocks
that was my first brand deal i ever did
wow it's from your set where to go
because i remember i drove up there to
their gym to do a video that was crazy
the brand deal i did it myself
like no managers no agent no nothing
they just reached out and they're like
we want five videos you just have to
wear the merch you don't have to you
don't have to call it out and then you
film a video like at our gym
cool and i have a video old old old
video and it actually did well on my
youtube was like different types of
people at the gym from like it was like
2017 and it's at the 5150 gym
and random and i forget how much they
paid me per video i think it was 150
bucks per video but at the time you're
like bro i don't have an income this
that's everything yeah and they dude
they sent me so many goddamn drinks i
would show up to like a pregame before
going out with a 24 pack of energy
drinks like trevor are you a [ __ ]
youth pastor right now what do you want
to have a heart attack tonight that is
crazy i was hanging on [ __ ] at the
bar
yeah i was like youth past i was like
there's no way i don't know what this is
and then you [ __ ] called it out 50
140. i went to high school with mikey
wow it's one of the first people he's
really like really i told you he's
hanging with the white kid cky kids
that's him well mikey he was the good
one he was the one like oh i'm not going
to do drugs every day with you yes i'm
just going to start an energy drink
company that
is also named after what is that code
when cops are crazy yeah crazy person
yeah they're like what do you want this
energy drink to be called the cycle yeah
guy with a spear running down lost
yeah i mean that's crazy dude the last
time i saw him i was working i was
selling packs from out of my [ __ ] car
at the p i used to deliver pizza and
sell weed out of my bag so i'd walk out
to my friend's house and pretend i'm
selling pizza in there and just have my
weed and scale yeah cause and who's
gonna [ __ ] pull me over but that's
the last time i saw that i said i'm
starting an energy drink company go [ __ ]
yeah yeah how random man that's crazy
good [ __ ] that's wild how
things kind of come full circle you know
that's a trip man wow um i have one more
thing i want to ask you yeah yeah it's
uh something we do called who were you
in the 90s oh wow i looked up and we're
almost we're right around the same age
so i know you're going to know most of
this [ __ ] and from our talk before we
started you're going to know most of
this [ __ ] so i'm just going to ask you
a question or i'm going to ask you pick
one or the other what would you pick
that's it so this is called who were you
in there from your perspective
okay ready yeah
vh1 or mtv
mtv same because what the [ __ ] you're
going to watch on vh1 as a kid yeah mtv
had like the badass people like the
ribs yeah they had crabs was crazy back
when they played the gorillas videos and
[ __ ] like it was fun
i couldn't imagine 2022 like people
showing off their house this is what i
have and inside come rob me
seriously true if you want to do cribs
i'll get an airbnb and sherman ellis and
i do a studio apartment like this is it
[ __ ] off yeah yeah i never thought
nothing yeah you wouldn't but dude
they're showing how much [ __ ] they have
and they show like an aerial view and
they're like he lives in toluca lake and
they're like we can find ludacris's
house
yes
but this was before like the deep
internet now it's like i wouldn't i
think they tried to bring it back
because like i would not post i thought
i have that i have uber east drivers
like recognize me and i'm like this is
weird and i have i got people off for
their breeds dude yeah because i have
people recognize me all the time and
then one time here i went it's weird
[ __ ]
i got a lot of [ __ ] in here i don't know
if you're a good guy yeah then you're
like kind of like fake lie you're like
no that's my girlfriend's house every
time i'm in my elevator like i'm set my
homies i'm like
[ __ ] i gotta get a house i gotta get
this
dude one time in my old apartment i
walked past they had this like window
that kind of like showed into the
courtyard they were watching my video as
i was walking oh [ __ ] i loved it but it
was cool but i had never talked to them
so i didn't know if they were like man
who is this guy or if it's by like
chances or i don't know it's just like
weird i was like oh god i got out of
here it's awesome though i i came up
behind somebody once watching my video
i'm like
[ __ ]
or the ups guy walked in
like [ __ ] right
you're getting you get high yeah yeah
you get high you do the weight on the
download you do the week i thought i
lived next to a like a raging porn star
when we lived in the park apartments for
the first year she had the pink hair
she's like shredded
boyfriend shredded camera crew following
him around like on the regular lived
right next door to me turned out to be
[ __ ] eva maria this huge wwe stuff oh
i know i know yeah yeah it took me a
long time to realize yeah i was like oh
no she's like an actual regular
celebrity
that's awesome yeah [ __ ] yeah um so
yes no more no more cribs that would
never happen so vh1 tmtv you got mtv
and then this is probably the hardest
one if you had to [ __ ] choose and i
know you're going to go through your
brain and go well
[ __ ] adam sandler or jim carrey if you
had to watch their movies for the rest
of your life uh it is so because love
them both i'm going sandler same adam
sandler just got some just water boy
so it's kind of hard to name them all
bro
it gets better you go but how do you
billy madison big daddy a little nicky
came around just [ __ ] nicki was the
first time i ever saw tits in a movie
was on his head yeah
i was like bro can you do this
is this your first time i ever saw booze
was total recall when the girl had three
boobs oh wow remember that arnold
schwarzenegger movie
but dude those
those girls gone wild commercials
with the stars of the nipples
that's really cool right now 1999
actually was better than porn because
you're like i don't know what the hell's
behind those stars but i need to and we
were six and then after right after that
jacqueline juicer so what you're going
to want to do
juice your cucumber commercials were
great at that they were dope and then
billy mays was there and the middle
guy and then they all just or died or
fell off we got to put billy mays and
the shamwa guy in the [ __ ] list billy
mays is dead
he could still make the who were you in
the night oh i thought you met the list
of kid on the show my bro he is gone oh
wow don't say this you just have a cut
out of him on the chair but love your
work man i love your work one of light
[Laughter]
you want multiple bumps billy maybe yeah
um
tupac or biggie smalls biggie
damn biggie just has a voice you hear an
uh
you hear that biggie has a voice for
rapping same way rick ross you hear me
go he's destiny a rapper biggie had that
[ __ ] he's got it like it's like he
fills out all of the music it feels like
there's no like you ever hear a rapper
who sounds like it's like a small guy in
a big room biggie had a tone where it
felt like he fit the music perfectly i
like your explanation he's great dude
yeah i got [ __ ] play because my mom's
from here and she's like no big smile is
not a good rapper thomas it's only tupac
so i didn't listen to the big deal
bro no two bucks great i'm being smalls
all day it's only [ __ ] two albums and
like that all day yeah just for me it's
more hip-hop [ __ ] for me yeah yeah
that's my [ __ ] but um
oh damn i haven't seen these in a minute
step by step or family matters god
that's hard
you know what no it's straight yeah yeah
people know what you think that matters
family step by step is cool but the
boyfriends and we're never that fun yeah
but you know steve urkel [ __ ] eddie
winslet's all i need uh oh
pulp fiction or forrest gump
pulp fiction yeah that movie was uh that
was like the first time i watched and i
was like this is [ __ ] this is tight i
think i even bought a pulp fiction
t-shirt after let's go his favorite
movie it's a great movie and that girl
the heroine girl uma
yeah wait oh you talking about the um
thurman or i thought you meant that his
[ __ ] wife the [ __ ] girl that's
freaking out about the needle
i don't know and then uh just the
[ __ ] the say what again that scene is
like
great like dude if you ever just if you
ever sober and you want that cocaine
feel just watch that scene that's a true
story that shit's [ __ ] what got me
hooked was phil lamarr remember phil
o'malley
was in that
everything about pulp fiction had such a
cool like feel and tone and aesthetic
and it still plays to this day you know
i can watch it tomorrow you just blew my
[ __ ] mind that that was the same dude
yeah it's dory oh my gosh
we're gonna get some [ __ ]
dorian comes up on the podcast every
other episode i don't know why they're
stuck in the 90s bro but it's okay i'll
[ __ ] live there forever it's fine
it's a great place oh god penny
no it's it the original it tim curry or
chucky
uh i wasn't really big on i was i was
only watching comedies yeah but i'd go
chucky because he had red hair and i had
red hair as a kid
i don't mean like it turned out i don't
mean like uh
who's cooler those you know what
oh what was yours which one were you
more scared of as a kid or chucky
chuck's name 18 years old
still an issue somehow the height of
chucky it's a voice for me
the voice he starts going
through the spell
yeah his face turns animatronic that
[ __ ] me up as a kid two two gingers of
one room is already enough [ __ ]
i level with me as a kid like yeah i got
a box right there do you swing do you
kick i always thought like i'd bury him
and then the part one came or they
buried him yeah but he got out oh that's
every scary movie in the 90s as they
like bury him then their like knife
comes out first and it's like
that [ __ ] me up dude he's in the he's
in the toy toy factory melting screaming
[ __ ] got me right now i'm in my 30s
[ __ ] this um okay here we go
easy mario or donkey kong
uh
you're the first person to hesitate
ever i might go donkey kong really yeah
no [ __ ] donkey kong
that's that's my guy right there's
[ __ ]
i've never heard anybody say it you
think you your brain wants to tell you
go mario but something about dk you're
like
dude that guy was like that's why i put
him on there he's legendary to a lot of
people i just i loved mario bros so much
the flowers and the spit
as a kid like mine was great too but you
know something about dong kong like
me you just feel like you're protected
but then i got a little italian and his
brother i'd be that guy who'd pick peach
every once in a while for mario kart
just to [ __ ] with people yeah i'd always
lose you know i was literally mario kart
bro i played the other day at the
[ __ ] dave and buster like
yeah [ __ ] you kid i lost dude i mean
it's these kids are built different yeah
it's draw off the mountain dew and
they're [ __ ] hot
yeah bro you're gonna be slower this
kid's [ __ ] almost i get it though but
about all the mushroom culture in those
early [ __ ] nintendo games right
they're mushrooms
all over the place you got the little
toad guys never thought about that bro
yeah they're [ __ ] spitting fire flame
like
chickens are [ __ ] right you're
honestly he starts flying
okay here we go oh damn okay remember
this is the 90s so if we're kids
mcdonald's bush or no bush [ __ ]
mcdonald's or burger king mcdonald's yep
i will say chicken fries from burger
king that was a hot era but that was
early 2000's yeah that was when i was
like in middle school i think then they
brought them back like i just thought
do you remember getting vhs's from
mcdonald's oh [ __ ] no no i had the
wayne's world with the mcdonald stamp
batman
fern gully
yeah they used to do dvds or
vhs you can buy for like 7.99 really
yeah when they would get the toy do you
want to buy the [ __ ] vhs wow yeah i
used to get them i have i think that was
just merced just flipping dvds
yeah they collab with blockbuster
straight up has a mcdonald's logo on it
though i mean that should yeah
the kids toy and all like those packages
used to be way doper growing up because
it would be a mcdonald's exclusive now
it's like oh yeah
you get the stuffed stuff i got the big
tall blue dude there'd be a beanie bag
in there and it'd be like wrapped in
like plastic with like fried grease on
it oh yeah if i would eat that chicken i
don't give a [ __ ]
crazy threw a toy in there with your
food i hear some plastic you should
taste it that's the smartest thing of
all this might just shut the hell out of
a kid give him food and give him
something to play with and you can't
drive past one without them [ __ ]
screaming for the [ __ ] toy yeah right
because because they had multiple toys i
need this one i only have that one yeah
but they wouldn't let you buy the other
one sometimes you can't just buy them
you can't it's a luck of the draw with
the [ __ ] [ __ ] the last two ones
these ones are this is a little harder
oh no michael jackson michael jordan oh
as a kid
as a kid as jordan right yeah i i think
it's just like
i love basketball growing up i couldn't
play for [ __ ] but just seeing what he
did it was just seeing
you ever seeing a
like a warm knife cut through butter
just seeing him like just paste it it's
just like
every kid wanted to be that yeah you
either owned his shoes or shirt or space
jam came out space we were hooked that
[ __ ] and we had seven foot hoops
at our elementary schools
i was touching that oh that was big the
day i touched that it was it was at the
top of your hallway dude there was a kid
in fifth grade who could dunk and i'm
like if this dude doesn't get a [ __ ]
pregnant
but like
so to see him do these crazy dunks and
then i could touch net in my head i was
like dude i'm i'm almost mj i guess i
had a michael jordan watch my grandma
got me i thought it was i was the dopest
[ __ ] ever dude i mean he just
global star yeah for sure like before
sprite and everybody took over with
kobe's and [ __ ] i think i was just too
young for michael jackson
which is a weird thing to say
you know
you know
you know
we're late enough in the episode we're
not getting demonetized and if we are
then [ __ ] it
yeah damn that was great yeah the first
time i ever heard about michael jackson
was the neverland ranch we actually
drove past me and my family where where
is that at we just had this conversation
i can't say no i mean is it in a town
like can you tell me not to say get the
[ __ ] out no no no no yeah i think it's
in california i think it's like
it's like uh i don't know where that's
at where do you get that property
i don't know but i remember
hearing about it and then i was like
that sounds kind of fun and my dad's
like whoa
wait a second here sir it does sound fun
of course of course it's supposed to be
the south park episode oh yeah take him
out like bro can i live here i'm cartman
minus i want to lay next to the small
yeah yo can i chill with the [ __ ]
dolphins right and the elephants yeah
real quick before we did you see the
south part pandemic episodes no
yourself a favor are they really good
they're all in their 30s now yeah they
are
so [ __ ] weird is it weird like when
they're old let me just drop one little
gem
mushrooms carbon's a jewish rabbi
really i'll just leave it at that's
intriguing enough to go wait what the
[ __ ] did i gotta watch it yeah it's
it's ridiculous bro it's only two
episodes but
it's good i've heard that from a few
people it's [ __ ] funny yeah um okay
last one
we always say this [ __ ]
uh that's a keenan and kill [ __ ] it's
orange soda or ness quick as a kid with
a light skinned rabbit
oh what uh between those yeah or the
light-skinned rabbit yeah or
nesquik yeah same too with that powder
[ __ ] how are you gonna [ __ ] tell me
anything else you know i might even get
crazy and get a strawberry milk every
once in a while that's what i used to do
yeah [ __ ] yeah i never mixed them but i
would [ __ ] strawberry milk up and i
drove cookies in it and ruin it but i
was a soda kid growing up but also but
the chocolate milk a good chocolate milk
still to this day i mean i wouldn't do
it in public but i'd get a chocolate
milk i wouldn't do it in public
yeah bro you can't be in your you can't
be 29 getting chocolates
right in my car in a lollipop
[ __ ] with a joint right here candy i can
do chocolate milk middle of the day
itches order one of the restaurants i'll
do a milkshake yeah chocolate milk it
could do it at a restaurant but yeah
it's like just fine
[ __ ] it i'm feeling it
like it's been a while exactly you got
to save some dumb cliche [ __ ] forever
21 t-shirt you deserve it if you work it
you know just get the chocolate milk i
think so your next one is all the dudes
that shop at h m
think of that one yeah i have a homie
that's he looks like a mannequin from h
m and i can not stop talking to you i
was trying to think about like doing
ones like the the designers of forever
21 i don't think they're still around
but like you the designers just like
they just throw it's like a normal
t-shirt then on the back they just put
some insane quote
live it be it free it show your tits
you're like what
the progressive mom eat love laughs oh
my god
that [ __ ]
what happens but there is a point in
life where you it just flip hit like you
something clicks and you're like that
shirt's hard i always wondered that like
am i going to be there one day and going
you know what
live laugh love is going to be i don't
see it happening yeah i remember growing
up i was like bro if i'm ever wearing
tennis shoes and jeans just take me out
and then one day i did it i was like
it's great this is great for agility
yeah this is great if a shopping cart
starts to go down the driveway you're
like bring that thing back you might
think i can't wear his footballs i'm
like yo what if someone starts trying to
fight me yeah like i gotta be aggressive
you ever seen those flip-flops that have
the beer opener on the bottom that's
peak white people right there that's
hilarious officer you're opening a beer
with something that you stepped in dog
[ __ ] with it's a good way to put it too
that is the ultimate white guy [ __ ] that
is like a jumbo cliff after yeah
there's sharks
and lions yeah had some lines yeah i
don't do any of the white people [ __ ]
marty doesn't either
well i do guys time to go pessimistic
rock climbing
bang
um
that was you who were you in the 90s
thank you of course just wanted to ask
these questions because i always want to
get a feel yeah the most well thought
out answers i think by far
yeah a lot of them need explaining you
know yeah most people just michael
jackson like [ __ ] why yeah sp
tell me um before we get here please
where can everybody find your shows i
think he brought him up trevor
wallacecomedy.com
trevor wallace comedy yeah i got a big
ass like 28 city tour starting next week
really yeah new orleans baby kicking it
off in the titty town itself uh dude
going everywhere oh tampa florida
milwaukee chicago dc pittsburgh columbus
trevor wallace comedy.com we'll overlay
dude
there's so many cities linked in the
description guys remember that in the
description but yeah dude it's going to
be a good time i mean i it's different
from the videos it's just stand up it's
just you know it's just a different part
of my brain and i've always loved to
keep the two separate so i think there's
a lot of similarities where you can you
can feel like there's a character coming
out in a bit or something like that but
it but it is uh you know it's just a
good time that's awesome dude is this
your biggest tour that you've done yeah
this is like the first like the other
ones have just been like comedy clubs
for you'll do a couple shows on a
weekend there but this is like one
nighter in a theater oh no [ __ ] each
city each night is a new city type of
feel so it's like it's kind of cool man
it's like it's feeling like a have you
been doing theaters or i've done a few
but this is the first like theater tour
run this is like this is like uh what
separates the boys from the men which is
you know interesting because i still
feel like i have so much to learn but uh
it's a it's a really big
kind of like moment to kind of like pat
yourself on the back like oh [ __ ]
actually congratulations
thank you man so i'm uh you know i'm
excited i'm nervous i'm anxious i have
every feeling i think i can have but
overall just excited that's [ __ ]
awesome so it's gonna be it's gonna be
wild man are you gonna put out a special
anytime soon
uh
i i think uh maybe at the end of this
tour since i'm gonna be doing the same
material i'll probably be pretty tired
of it by the end and i'll probably want
to put it on camera but if i do sick if
not you know i'll get i don't want to
rush the special because then you get
people just
[ __ ] well you got to be on that [ __ ]
i feel like you might be a perfectionist
when it comes to this yeah so it's
you're going to be sitting all up all
night oh i rushed it i [ __ ] rushed it
right exactly
and yeah and it's hard because you know
you can sit on it forever until the
right moment is but there never really
is a right moment uh and if there is a
right moment it might be right for you
but not for like a network you're like
i'm ready they're like we don't give a
[ __ ] you're 43 shut up
but if somebody like hulu or netflix or
hbo max is like yeah we we came to your
last show in los angeles we loved it we
want to buy it then that's when you sit
down with yourself and be like all right
is this am i happy putting this out am i
doing this for the money or am i doing
this because i'm ready you know yeah
that's the biggest thing you figured out
and then you look dead in the camera you
go [ __ ] i'm doing this for the money
[ __ ] it dude [ __ ] it yeah i can still
make more [ __ ] no i'm i'm excited just
for everything that's coming i don't
know what it is but i'm excited for it
well congrats man that's a huge deal 28
cities yeah it's some something crazy
are you doing your hometown uh
the last stop is in los angeles yeah
but uh we're going to be in l.a so for
everyone out here oh the nova yeah it's
in downtown i [ __ ] with that that's
right i used to live across the street
in uh l.a live area yeah [ __ ] yeah
nobody's that's the biggest theater i'm
doing on this on this
channel lenovo 1200 people 1500 1500 a
lot of [ __ ] people holy [ __ ] people i
know bro but luckily it's the last one
on the tour so you know i can like build
up the hype and you know show people
like snippets of what it is and uh you
know i perform in la so much that
everyone's like yeah we can pay you know
theater prices go cmr we see him at the
lab factory for seven dollars and it's
like
you know there's a difference though man
somebody in their [ __ ] spot yeah
it'll it'll be and it'll be the last
show the tour so this [ __ ] the material
is going to be tight it's going to be
[ __ ] seasoned it's going to be good
it's going to be i'm excited for it you
know i feel happy about it i don't feel
like this theater this tour is rushed i
feel like excited and it's not like
it doesn't feel like a money grab at all
which is which is a good because
whenever you feel like something's
forced it your audience can feel it
we're about to start doing live shows
yeah our first one
yeah nice man that live show uh land is
it's a whole different ball game but
it's fun man it's a different type of
energy you know oh for sure we have
nobody to impress that marty but but you
know you're doing a live show you're
like oh
why is that person have their arms
folded why aren't you so you know but it
is but but when the jokes are hidden and
people are responding that live energy
is just unbeatable
so man it went from your mom saying you
should do this you have a personality
that's crazy it's a [ __ ] dick grab
elephant walks but not for real yeah and
now you're doing your theater shows yeah
it doesn't make sense very cool though
dude it's cool i know you're thinking
back when i was 15 like [ __ ] ear
shows yeah so [ __ ] love man you gotta
look back a little bit sometimes uh
compare the two because i think we're
always looking ahead but you always have
to high five your younger self like yeah
jobs keep going hey man smoke that weed
out of that light bulb exactly who gives
a [ __ ] who cares bro yeah you're gonna
get paid to laugh right yeah
it's uh it's really cool man and i think
uh looking back is definitely an
important factor yes so youtube just
trevor wallace youtube trevor wallace
instagram trevor welcome to trevor
wallace uh all of them but twitter
twitter's just some other redhead guy
who hasn't posted in years uh might be
deceased i don't know
we've tried to get his name but i don't
even use twitter anymore it's so i just
you know i got uh you know tick tock
instagram so above all else travel
wallacecomedy.com
yeah that's website trouble.com remember
guys in the description check out some
tickets go [ __ ] support go hang out
have fun
thank you so much for being on the show
man of course bro it was a great time
you guys do a great job thank you for
being here dude um
anything else
ah guys
january 28th netflix and from the cold
go support that oh yes team there it is
for netflix i didn't want to forget
about that but yeah i know i know we've
had so many guests for what a month that
we we usually do solo episodes we'll be
like [ __ ] three hours long yeah
and we update everybody on live but it's
a big project we talked about it on
instagram i just wanted to make sure we
mentioned that because it's going to
come out by the time this one comes out
but yeah a lot of some of the most
important people we work with tied to
this show on netflix and from the cold
let's go support that support that guys
thank you so much oh yeah but above all
right before we get out of here trevor
wallace.com
for all tickets thank you so much for
being here dude yeah appreciate you
having me it's a great time guys this
has been the dope usual podcast thank
you for being here have a dope ass day
two episodes no smoking wow i feel like
a [ __ ] do you feel any different when
doing episodes smoking or no no i'm just
i'm always high
[Music]
perfect
[Music]